knowing what you don't want helps you to
know what you do want doesn't it
someone said to us one day when we were
trying to get them to focus upon
positive things and we sort of laid out
a list of positive things that she might
think about and she said oh abraham i
don't want those i've already got those
and what she really meant was
the things that i want are the things
that have not yet happened and we want
to help you to realize that if you're
thinking about things that you want from
the standpoint that they have not yet
come to fruition that they are still
missing in your experience
then
you're holding it in a sort of
suspended position where the distance
between where you are and where it is is
not closing
so what we're wanting you to realize is
you have these patterns of thought and
law of attraction is helping you to
sustain the pattern of thought that you
have a belief is just a thought you keep
thinking and so early on in your
experience by your exposure to life you
began developing some patterns of
thought sometimes they were carefully
taught to you by others
sometimes it came because of something
that you observed and then talked about
and then remembered and then attracted
again and then talked about it and then
remembered and then attracted again in
other words life is very interesting
here isn't it because you can't talk
about anything for very long before it
begins to replicate itself in your life
experience and it's what makes you
develop your patterns of what you call
truths
you say
at first i wasn't sure and then i
pondered it for a while
and once i gave it my attention
i began seeing evidence of it everywhere
and now i believe it and now that i
believe it it's manifesting in my
experience and we say that's really
wonderful isn't it if it's stuff you
want
but if you are repeating patterns of
thought about things you do not want
and in your environment oh you are very
very good at that you have this
sort of mass consciousness theory that
goes like this
if we don't beat the drum of our history
we are sure to repeat it again and we
say
the contrary is true
the more you beat the drum of anything
the more you activate it in your
vibration the more it is activated in
your vibration
then the more law of attraction is
matching you up with things like it and
the more law of attraction is matching
you up with things like it the more you
observe it and the more you observe it
the more you talk about it the more you
talk about it and observe it the more
you beat the drum of it or offer the
vibration of it the more you offer the
vibration of it the more law of
attraction matches you up with it the
more law of attraction matches you up
with it the more you're living it the
more you're talking about it the more
you're beating the drum of it the more
you're offering the vibration of it the
more you're offering the vibration of it
the more the law of attraction lines you
up with it the more law of attraction
lines you up with it the more you notice
it the more you notice it the more you
talk about it the more you talk about it
the more you offer it vibrationally the
more you offer it vibrationally the more
law of attraction lines you up with it
the more law of attraction we could go
on
your life experience is showing you that
you just cannot keep telling the same
story without continuing to live the
same circumstances and so this gathering
we're calling it the art of allowing but
what it really means is the art of
telling a different story the art of
telling the story the way life has
helped you carve it out incrementally
but telling the story with your words
with your observations with your
expectations with your vibration
then when law of attraction is
responding to your deliberate offering
of thought now you're getting what you
want not just what you're observing want
to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some amazing
wisdom from abraham hicks
enjoy
rule number two go with the stream
imagine taking your canoe down to the
river's edge
a very nice fast moving stream and your
oars or paddles are already attached to
your boat and you put it in the water
and you deliberately turn it upstream
and begin paddling very hard against
this fast moving current
and we say
why not just turn and go with the flow
and our human friends
invariably say
doesn't that seem lazy
that seems lazy
and then they will say
my mother would not approve of that
or my teachers
they all had me pointing the other way
in fact every plaque on my wall was
based upon paddling upstream
[Laughter]
and i was measured against the others
who did it too
and
the better we did it the better we were
able to fight that current then the more
proud our human friends were of us and
the bigger the trophies and monuments
and we hear that when you die there are
even more
[Laughter]
and we want you to know something in
fact it's worth writing this down
nothing that you want is upstream
nothing that you want is upstream and
the reason we know that is because we've
seen the cycle of life we know that
source extended itself here into that
which is you and we know that you are
asking as a result of your leading edge
experience just like you knew you would
for more and we know that source is
becoming that more that you are asking
for and is calling you to it and so we
know the source of the stream
and we know that when you turn and go
with the stream you feel ever so good
that's what positive emotion is varying
degrees of it but it's what positive
emotion is and we also know that when
you buck that current it can beat up on
you pretty good and that's what negative
emotion is
we want you to understand that there is
only one stream that you might be going
with or against but there is only one
stream and when you learn from those
around you to go against the stream then
you want to pronounce that there are
evil streams that there are streams of
sickness or streams of badness or
streams of poverty we say no just one
stream you're just not going with it
you say oh that can't be if it's a
stream of goodness why is it beating me
up so and we say because you're clinging
to the bottom
it's beating you up because you're not
going with your self-created stream do
you get this
and
that really is the strongest point that
we want to make with you
this stream of well-being is a powerful
stream and it takes you downstream
whether you go easily or not
in other words when you look around at
your environment you've just got to
acknowledge that well-being abounds your
planet continues to spin in its orbit
and
even beyond the well-being that is
obvious more obvious to some of you than
others granted but even beyond the
well-being that is obvious we want to
remind you that even when you get
further downstream and you have that
which you call your physical death which
there isn't any of we like to be
disrespectful of death since there isn't
any call it croaking
when you when you croak
you really move rapidly with this stream
of well-being in other words the stream
of well-being is not only dominant it's
all that there is
so while you can be in this physical
body and you can fume and fuss and give
yourself a lot of grief and point in
opposition of the stream to the point
that you beat yourself up pretty good
and then claim that there cannot
possibly be a stream of well-being
because your life is going so badly we
want to say to you if you would let go
of your resistance and start going with
the flow you will discover how good this
stream can be to you rule number three
tune to the frequency everything is
tremendous tremendous teaching but when
it comes to the channeling i'm like
i get lost well actually it
it's a good thing that you don't in this
sense we don't want it to be something
so
unusual either because
the fact is
everyone
that who you see around you is an
extension of source energy and everyone
has access to this broader
knowing
in fact
through the years as
our way of explaining who we are
and who you are and how it all blends
together has evolved
this analogy that we offer about this
vortex this vibrational
place isn't even the right word
vibrational state of being
where if you tend to your vibration then
you enter the vortex and you become one
with what's there that's the best
definition of channeling that anyone
could ever give
a basketball player who learns his skill
who
gets tuned in to the rhythm of who he
really is
often describes being in the zone
and it's not so different from being in
the vortex in fact
some of his
extraordinary abilities when he's really
tuned in like that of being able to
recognize his time and space of being
able to judge the distance from where he
is and the trajectory of the ball that
he is throwing in other words all of
that is because he is using more of his
resources
scientists have long said that humans
use but a small percentage of their
mental capacity even as their probing
brains and putting contraptions on them
to measure activity and so you're really
accurate when you acknowledge that
everyone the beasts of your planet are
all doing it all of the time in other
words they are not they have not given
up their awareness of their relationship
with their source energy in order to
please others the domesticated ones tend
to do it more but for the most part the
beasts of your planet are tuned to that
frequency it's why you can see a flock
of birds flying in formation in perfect
perfect rhythm with one another it's
because they are operating out of the
one mind to which they are all
vibrationally in sync
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four move up the
emotional scale do you understand that
you never get it done and you cannot get
it wrong
and the reason that you can't get it
wrong is because it's never done
so even though it may sound or feel
out of balance
and maybe even wrong
that
it really isn't wrong because
in the feeling of wrongness you're
giving birth to your opinion of what
would be rider
and the source within you so trusts
your opinion of what would be better for
you
that the source within you embraces that
idea completely
and becomes a vibrational equivalent to
it
and holds steady there
until you find your way there
we've talked about the fun of croaking
you're still not there are you
we've talked about the deliciousness of
releasing resistance through what you
call the death experience
and we've talked about releasing
resistance through
meditation quieting the mind
we've talked about releasing resistance
through
appreciation but you have to be
somewhere in the vicinity of
appreciation to release resistance
but do you know
with every feeling of relief that you
find as you make your way up the
emotional scale
with every feeling of relief there is
the releasing of resistance
and so every effort that you make to
release every little resistance is
really worth the effort because in time
because of the vastness of the variety
of your life
the subjects that are alive and active
in your now
are enough for you to release all
resistance that you've accumulated over
a lifetime do you know that
you don't have to go back
and make peace with some wrongdoing that
happened
20 years ago or 30 years ago or
yesterday
you don't have to go back and fix all of
those things because whatever is active
in your vibration now is bringing you
current real life active poignant
meaningful now
matches
you're attracting the vibrational
evidence that shows you
what you're doing do you know that what
you're living and the way it is playing
out
is your vibrational indicator do you
know what's going on in your body is
just an indicator of your vibration do
you know that what's happening in your
life in terms of relationship is just a
vibrational indicator do you know the
money in your bank account is a
vibrational indicator
everything that is manifested the car
that you're driving the house that
you're living in the clothes that you're
wearing the condition of your body
everything about your life
is a vibrational indicator
and those indications of vibration are
being shown to you all day every day in
the form of the emotion that you feel
so if you leave here with one decision
within you and it goes like this
i now understand the importance of
recognizing how i feel and i do care
about feeling as good as i can feel
about that and that and that
so somebody you love tells you a lie and
it hits you hard
and you think they shouldn't lie to me
they should trust me more i wish they
wouldn't lie and then you try to wrestle
them to the ground and you try to figure
out why they are lying and you try to
figure out where the lies started and
you try to understand the motive of the
line and all you do is get yourself in a
scramble because you can't begin to
understand it you couldn't sort it out
if you had 100 lifetimes to do it
but you can recognize that your
attention to this subject is causing you
discomfort right here and now and you
could choose a better feeling thought
so you find a thought that goes
something like i don't understand where
they're coming from and that gives you a
little relief and then you think of a
thought such as well i have told a lie
before and that might make you feel
better too
and then you think a thought such as
the only time i've ever lied was because
i didn't think the person would like
what i thought to be the truth and i
wanted them to feel as good as they
could feel so maybe there is some
compassion in lying somewhere and you
feel a little better and then you think
i don't know why i'm making such a big
thing about this and then you think
i can't even remember what the subject
hand was and then you think
i think i've been making a big deal out
of nothing and then you think this is a
person who i really love and then you
think
it really doesn't matter what they're
doing it really only matters how i feel
about them and then you think
i should not ask them to behave in
certain ways in order to love them
because i am one who offers
unconditional love
and as you work your way through issue
after issue with person after person and
subject after subject before you know it
within one or two or three days
certainly four or five and absolutely
within 30 you will have had enough real
life experiences show you
the vibrational evidence of what's going
on with your vibration that you can
clean it all up within 30 days you can
have cleaned up enough of your vibration
and by cleaning up all we mean is find a
better feeling thought find a better
feeling thought find a better feeling
thought find a better feeling thought
that do you know that you are 30 days or
less
from being a vibrational match to the
source that is really you
to the reason that you were born to the
coming forth into this physical
experience to the living the joyous life
experience that you've come to live to
the being a vibrational match to what's
in your vibrational escrow to the
getting inside everything that you've
ever asked for do you know how close you
are in terms of time
having everything that life so far has
caused you to ask for
it's such a short distance
it just requires some caring about how
you feel
and a willingness to move yourself
deliberately up the emotional scale and
back into vibrational alignment with who
you really are
as you do that every day you'll see the
world a little more through the eyes of
source
and as you begin to view your
magnificent world
through the eyes of source you will then
revel in your beingness
and in that of others
and you will feel pride and worth
beyond physical description
and you will begin to express to others
i've come forth with great reason
into this physical body and that reason
is for joyous expansion and i wish that
for all rule number five
ask if i am to understand that we create
our own reality through our
thoughts powered by our feelings
not powered by your feelings indicated
by your feelings indicated by our
feelings the power
and the combined thought becomes more
powerful and law of attraction
responding to it is the real engine
feelings indicate
so how does this work with the people in
burma and china over the past few weeks
that have suffered such tragedies
well we know it's hard to hear and
and
we're going to explain it from broad
perspective
the first thing that we so want you to
remember is that
what you call death
that you all dread so is not like you
think it is in other words it's just
re-emerging in the fullness of that
which you are
and in the same way that
a
woman suffering from
the negativity of her own life
and therefore causing the breakdown of
her own body
finds alzheimer's as
the bridge
into the pure positive energy
there are many populations who find
catastrophes that are hard to understand
from the outside
point of view as a bridge into pure
positive energy
if you start with the premise that is
the valid premise that we know that you
are
joy-seeking beings who are coming forth
for the joy of life
and you come from source from a vantage
point of understanding not just that joy
is your quest but that joy is your
legacy that it is your inherited right
is it not inconceivable that you could
be set up for
tragedy and for trauma and for
the horrors of death in other words you
just have to with all of this begin to
wrap your minds around
another way of understanding what you
call life and death that we are calling
life and more life and more life
we said a little bit ago that
when you look at the broad view of who
you are
this experience that you call my whole
life in this body is such a short snap
of an experience that
from the broader point of view
there is a
a humorous
adoring
respect for the way you see your lives
with all of its trauma and drama that is
just not understood or experienced from
non-physical perspective
it would be like
you
walking into a movie that someone had
told you was going to be really good and
in the first scene you say this is the
most horrible thing i've ever seen and
just getting up and walking out
and the others in the theater
then having a funeral for you
and being horrified that you didn't hang
in there with them and see the movie to
the end
when you said this isn't the kind of
movie i wanted to see and i've had
enough of this off i go
so the first premise that is flawed is
the idea that death is a bad thing
so
we understand we hear it often people
say if i create my own reality then how
do you explain
a large number of people creating such a
horrific or even a common reality and we
say well when you think about how it is
that most people offer almost all of
their vibration in response to what they
are observing
it makes you understand that
it's not an unusual thing for a
population to have a similar vibrational
offering because most of them are not
thinking purposefully most of them are
observing and therefore having a
knee-jerk response to what they are
observing
then law of attraction exaggerates that
because you think a thought which causes
you to feel away and it also causes you
to set up a point of attraction which
causes you to experience something which
then you observe which causes you to
offer a vibration which you then observe
which causes you to offer a vibration
and so there are these patterns you see
it as you travel around the world you
see different segments of your world
vibrating similarly you see
and so it is not surprising that people
in
areas would offer similar enough
vibrations that they would co-create an
event but then we want you to step back
even further and realize we said it just
a little bit ago and let's exaggerate it
here again
that there are three steps to the
creative process and whether you know it
or not whether you become a deliberate
creator one who is deliberately offering
thought and therefore deliberately
adjusting your vibration for the
deliberate point of receiving something
or whether you are like so many people
in fact most people who are offering
your vibration by default in other words
you're just observing and and your
vibrations are flowing all over the
place
in in as you are offering your vibration
and law of attraction is responding to
your vibration your resulting life
experience is coming
in response to what you're offering
vibrationally you just cannot get around
it as you think you vibrate as you
vibrate you attract as you attract you
receive
so
whether you know it or not you are
sifting through this contrast and in
those experiences that you or almost
anybody would call a not wanted
experience a very remarkable thing is
happening in that not wanting experience
there is a powerful launching of what is
wanted and so
huge segments of your population are
putting great desire over here in
vibrational escrow but the confines of
their environment
seemingly prevents them from going with
the flow of what they're asking for and
so while someone like you could easily
experience contrast and and you feel
more free to turn your attention to what
you want and line up with it
some in fact many cannot do that and the
fastest way for them to achieve
alignment with what this life has caused
them to ask for is by re-emerging into
non-physical
so
large segments of your population are
putting forth wonderful things into a
vibrational escrow the future
generations even the generations that
remain
beyond them
in your now time space reality will
benefit from you see
and so from that broader vantage point
there is no sacrifice now i want to be
clear about something
three parts to the creative process step
one says ask well are they ever ever
doing that
sometimes people will say in
appreciation of jerry and esther and
abraham thank you for coming forth to
answer and we always say these answers
could not be here
if someone were not asking expansion
cannot take place without asking and so
do not underestimate the power of the
asking the power of the asking and do
you know that there are so many who are
coming forth from non-physical that
understand the power of the answering
that never
were not hung up on the idea of asking
and aligning and allowing and receiving
they came forth to ask in very powerful
ways knowing that they would contribute
mightily to what is being answered and
so if you can step back and get that
point of view that source point of view
then you become one who is at ease with
experiences rule number six trust the
process
so there is a
vibrational version of you
that is preceding you
even now you are in this physical body
just like that vibrational version of
you preceded you before you came into
this physical body
and when this leading edge
genius creative
physical you
explores contrast and gives birth to a
new desire that non-physical part of you
rides that rocket and becomes it that's
what that feeling of excitement or
expectation is
when you feel that joyous positive
emotion that means that you are within
the vibrational vicinity of this
powerful attraction and the sensation to
you is that it's like a powerful river
that is moving downstream and if you
even stick your toe in it the river will
sweep you with its current toward what
you are wanting
and when you understand that everything
that you want is within that current and
it is moving downstream and you begin to
relax and allow yourself to go with that
steady flow
everything that you want will begin
showing up in your experience
we see so many of you you take your raft
or your boat down to the river's edge
and you get
into the raft and almost without
exception you turn it upstream and begin
paddling very hard
we know it is illogical isn't it and we
say why not
go with the flow
and our human friends think about it
briefly and then say
that just seems lazy
the people who try hard look at them all
look how hard they try
and those are the ones who are rewarded
i learned it when i was little the
harder you try the better things will go
for you and there is no gain without
pain i was told that over and over and
over again and since i want
gain then i want pain
so
get out of my way and let me paddle look
how strong i am becoming
and then they point out to us all the
other strong ones that are virtuous and
valiant and paddling upstream too
and we listen
politely
because we have seen the big picture and
we know who you are and we know why you
came and we know that everything that
you want is downstream
and that nothing that you want is
upstream
without knowing it most of our human
friends have picked up very upstream
habits you've been trained by others who
have been
paddling upstream very hard
and the art of allowing is about letting
go of those oars
and it's easy to let go of the oars when
you know that everything that you want
is downstream and when you know that the
source energy within you is down there
tending what you are wanting
but when you believe that you have to
work hard when you believe that struggle
is inherent in achieving
then while we will admit that you can
move some physical things around
we have to say to you
that creation through action is mediocre
at best in terms of the results it
brings to you
and that
creation through alignment of energy is
where all of the masters and all of
those that you revere
have found their place
you cannot be
a magnificent creator
without alignment to the energy of the
power that creates worlds
and when you hold yourself apart from it
you know it you feel rotten and when you
find yourself aligning to it you feel
wonderful
isn't it nice that you were born with a
guidance system that lets you easily
know from wherever you stand if the
thought you are choosing to say right
now if the thought you're thinking of
the words you were speaking you can tell
by the way you feel if it's upstream in
nature or downstream in nature
the way you are feeling right now won't
tell you the best thought you've ever
thought it will only tell you the
directional choice of your thoughts it
will let you know if you're going to
ward what you want or away from what you
want toward who you really are or away
from who you really are
jedi and esther went white water rafting
and it was such a fun day
and as they put their boat in the water
there were a lot of them that went six
of them went together and
several other rafts full of high school
wrestlers
and as they put their boat in the water
not one of them even thought about
turning the raft upstream
they knew that fast-moving river was
going to have its way with them nobody
even thought about paddling upstream
and the river guide said to them first
thing friends this is not disneyland
we cannot turn this river off
and this is the thing that we most want
to say to you
we could not turn this river off
further
you're the one who made the river go so
fast
you hit the ground running when you were
born you had so much intention and all
day every day you're sifting through
that data of life and asking asking
asking asking asking you're the reason
the river's moving fast and you're the
reason that you're going with it or not
you have total control in all of this
and nothing that you are doing has
anything to do with anybody else or
anybody else's river in other words stay
out of their boat
and don't invite them in your boat in
other words the only awareness that you
need to have if you want to utilize the
guidance system that you were born with
you want to know one thing and one thing
only moment by moment thought by thought
is this upstream or downstream and then
the next statement is how can i make it
more downstream how can i turn this
thought and this feeling more downstream
what could i do to soften the resistance
what could i do to release the
resistance a little more and trying
harder is the wrong answer
trying harder makes the resistance more
it's letting go of the ores that makes
it less it's trusting the process it's
trusting the stream and rule number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus clips is no
you are a creator you keep saying you
can be do or have anything you want if
this environment
has the wherewithal to inspire a desire
within you this environment has the
wherewithal to deliver it to you no
exceptions can you give us a rampage of
invincibility so that i feel invincible
we're going to start where you are and
and build you into the vibration
that is necessary for you to be or do or
have anything that you want
i am
beginning to understand that i am more
than i see here in this physical body
i acknowledge that there is a larger
part of me a source energy part of me
that is truly the essence of who i am
and i accept that a part of that
consciousness is now flowing in this
physical body and so there's a sort of
duality going on within me where i have
this stable beginning and becoming and
then there is the part of me that is
focused here in this physical body and i
understand
with clarity
the value of the two parts of that which
i am
i can feel the eternalness of who i
really am and i can feel the specifics
of who i am in this human form
on this leading edge time space platform
and i am beginning to feel appreciation
for the contrast that surrounds me that
once i condemned now i embrace because i
can feel that the contrast is inspiring
yet another new idea from me and i
remember feeling a new idea being born
within me and hating the birthing of it
because it was an idea that i did not
believe and therefore it brought me pain
but now i'm experiencing the thrill of
giving birth to ideas and even though i
don't know how or when or who
it will come about i don't know where i
don't have the details of how it will
unfold i do have faith or belief in the
laws of the universe and i am knowing
that i am a creator who having given
birth to this idea will be given all of
the advantages of the resources of
source in order to accomplish it
so while i stand in this place of
wanting something that i have no way of
figuring out how it's going to be
i am feeling soothed in the awareness of
it no more than soothed i not only feel
soothed about having given birth to an
idea of something that i want i'm
feeling enlivened by it because the
larger part of me knows unequivocally
that i am the creator of my own
experience and that larger part of me is
not only looking at it and agreeing with
it but has become the vibrational
equivalent of it in fact the larger part
of me has already become what i'm asking
for and so now it's only a matter of the
rest of me catching up with it and now
that i know what i know i don't think
this is going to be too much trouble
when i move in the direction of catching
up with it i feel better and when i move
in opposition of catching up with it i
feel worse and i am so sensitive the way
that i'm feeling these days i'm so proud
of myself because i'm aware of when i'm
going with the flow and when i'm not i'm
aware of when i'm moving downstream and
when i'm moving upstream i can feel when
i'm letting myself be who i have become
and i can feel when i'm not letting
myself be who i've become
and i'm no longer mad at myself in the
moments that i'm not letting myself be
who i've become because those moments
only help me to know the difference in
the guidance system i can feel i'm
actually molding the clay
i'm finally in the place where i don't
need to be the manifested receiver of
everything that i want all at once
because i know that it's all coming that
there will never be a time that i will
not be sending more rockets of desire
into my future i'm finally beginning to
get it that i never get it done and i
cannot get it wrong because everything
that i'm living is causing an expansion
and i can tell by the way i feel whether
i'm moving toward that expansion or not
finally i'm beginning to understand that
it was never about the fulfillment or
the manifestation anyway these things
that i want are only my target to focus
upon so that i can ride this river of
life
i am fulfilled in the knowing that i am
expanding and i am thrilled in the
knowledge that i will never get it done
and i am satisfied deeply satisfied with
where i am
i'm thrilled in knowing that i am where
i am and that i'm putting the boat in
the water wherever i am and my knowledge
that the stream is flowing downstream
ever flowing toward all that i have
become is enough for me to feel
satisfaction in where i am no more will
i nitpick as i measure the distance
between where i am and where i want to
be instead i flow on this joyous river
and i experience the exhilarating
feeling of motion toward my expansion
i can feel that the source within me
loves me and adores me and has become
the expanded version and i can feel that
there's no remorse or discomfort
whatsoever in the being of my source my
source not for a moment looks at me
where i stand and compares where i am to
where it is and mocks me in the not
achievement instead the source within me
that is expanded as a result of what i
have lived stands in loving appreciation
of all that i have become and calls me
never-endingly toward it and now i get
it that that's what life is that the
duality of me that the source energy
that was willing to come forth that
expanded out further and now the
physical part of me that's willing to
catch up i now get my place in this
universe i'm important to the expansion
of the universe and it's time for me to
receive the benefit of my expansion and
now i know how
i think we get
we all get certain ahas
and that's when we sort of learn
something we say oh okay
and then if we can keep that
what we've learned and practice it
then we've made another step and we can
move forward
um
yes it's a lifetime journey and we never
stop learning i'm 80 and i'm still
learning
though the lessons are easier now than
they used to be i like to think of that
when we start we have all these boulders
in front of us on our pathway and we
start to get the boulders out of the way
and you finally get to the point where
it's gravel
and gravel you can handle
you know and you can sweep gravel and
you can do things
so and then occasionally there's an old
boulder
that rolls back into your bed
you think oh i thought i i thought i had
that one
but not completely
and you know also i think that when we
learn lessons we think oh i've learned
that one it'll never happen again i've
done that and that's it
well how do you know you've done it
unless it comes by once more
and see how you react have you really
learned it is it really nothing for you
have you gone beyond that or are you
going to go right back into the same old
reaction
see we're never wrong
that's what we need to learn that we're
always doing the best we can with the
understanding and awareness and
knowledge we have at that moment you
know so many people think that money is
the most important thing in the world if
they don't have money they would just
die but that's not true
there's a substance that is far more
precious and far more important to us
that we literally can't live without
what is that
love no plenty of people are miserable
and lonely most of their life and and
and live
air your air your breath your breath is
the most important thing that you have
the most precious thing if you didn't
take another breath you wouldn't last
three minutes and you'd never get out of
this room
and yet we absolutely take for granted
that our next breath is there look at us
we're all in this room breathing and i'm
not saying don't breathe there's not
enough for me
we assume that it's there
and when we exhale we don't think about
where's my next breath coming from
now
if the power that created us
has given us enough breath to last for
as long as we shall live
can we not begin to trust that the other
things will take care of themselves
see life is here for us life is here to
support us to take care of us to be here
for us the entire planet has been put
here for us to play with
we have everything that we shall ever
need it's already here only we have to
know it and we have to trust it and we
have to acknowledge it
do you realize that there is more food
on this planet than people could
possibly eat there's an incredible
amount of food yes it is true that there
are people starving
but the food is here
there is more money on this planet than
we know how to count the money is here
now there are lots of people who are
very broke but the money is here
there are billions of people on this
planet
and yet you will have people tell you
that they're lonely
it has nothing to do with not being
people
it's what we're doing with our heads
everything is here for us for every dis
ease on this planet there is a plant
that will cure it
everything everything is here for us
and the more we begin to trust life
and acknowledge the beauty and
magnificence of our own being the more
we find everything we need it just pops
up everything you think and everything
you speak goes out from you into the
universe and comes back to you
multiplied uh it's almost as though the
universe is listening to everything you
say and everything you think and saying
oh that's what they want
but most of the time we are talking very
negatively about ourselves we talk about
how awful we are we're not good enough
we can't get this we can't get that how
can the universe bring you anything good
if that's the way you're talking well
the simple part that most people don't
understand is that every thought we
think in every word we speak
is creating our future
it's as though our thoughts go out into
the universe and are
accepted and brought back to us as
experience
now that is a very simple thing but most
people don't get it they don't
understand it they've never heard it
before and they think it's ridiculous
but if you can really accept the fact
that every time you think a thought and
every time you speak a word you are
literally painting your future
making your dinner uh whatever you want
to call it you are creating
[Music]
and you're creating your own life
and this is simple
but it's not easy
to accept but once you accept it then
you can start deliberately
creating what you want in your life
and you begin to be aware
of what you don't want in your life and
how you are contributing to it
now i think this has been around forever
but for some reason in the last 20 years
the universe has wanted this to go out
among all the people or all the people
that are ready for it see most of us
just think they think think think think
think and we don't pay any attention to
what we're thinking we're just doing it
but that's something you need to train
yourself to do to begin to train
yourself to be aware of what you're
thinking
and and one of the ways to do that is to
periodically say to yourself what am i
thinking
would i like this thought to create my
life
would i like to have the experience that
this got thought could bring to me
now it takes a while to do that but even
if we could begin on the smallest level
to be aware of our thinking we can start
to make changes i know that you've heard
me say many times or you've read or
listened on the tapes that loving
yourself
is the most powerful thing we can do
then everything flows
everything flows beautifully i'm not
talking about
vanity or arrogance because that is not
love that's always fear
i'm talking about just really respecting
and appreciating this incredible
magnificent being that we are
you know little babies know how to love
themselves you were born in pure love
all of you there's not one little baby
alive i that i know of that ever
criticizes its body
or ever says my hips are too big have
you ever heard a baby say that
[Applause]
they're just thrilled and delighted that
they have a body
and they rejoice in it and they love
themselves they love their toes they
love everything about themselves they
absolutely adore they
express their feelings
you know when a baby is happy you know
it when a baby is angry the whole
neighborhood knows it they're never
scared to let people know how they feel
they live in the moment and they're
filled with courage
and they're wonderful and we were all
like that
got to remember that you were filled
with courage and you were full of love
and you adored yourself when you were
very little to begin with you start by
doing what we call doing affirmations
and that is making positive statements
about your life
that
are positive
and you do them deliberately you might
do them in the morning you might do them
at noon you might do them at night
you might do them you know
twice a day or whatever but you do this
and you let this become a habit
and as you start to do them
things will begin to change maybe on a
very small level i call it getting the
green lights from the parking places i
mean they're not huge things in your
life it can be very nice when you get
three green lights in a row
and you're in a hurry
doing an affirmation is either writing
it down writing it on the wall or the
mirror or using a
you know just saying it what i like
people to do is to stand in front of a
mirror and do their affirmations
because there's something very powerful
about looking in your own eyes
and getting
and accepting yourself or noticing that
you reject yourself when you're saying
something positive about yourself
so that would be a very
beginning way to start
say in the morning you get up in the
morning you go to the mirror and this is
a big one and it's hard for lots of
people
but you look in the mirror and i say and
say i love you
i really really love you
and to begin with that can be so hard
for people because they think of all the
things that they think are wrong with
them but if you can start your day
saying that it's very powerful
remember i'd like to think the universe
is listening to everything you say and
everything you think and saying okay you
can get that
so then it starts to bring you in and
bring things into you and i know this
sounds far fetched but it's amazing how
it works
if you do a good general
positive statement for yourself
the universe will figure out how to
manifest that
how to bring that about in your life
so things could happen that you wouldn't
expect at all
but they will happen
if you think of doing your positive
affirmations is like planting a seed in
the ground it's not necessarily true at
the moment but it is something you want
to have be true
so you put the seed in
and you you you plant a seed and you
expect it to grow
you maybe plant three seeds just in case
you expect them to grow and you don't
wait two days and then dig in the earth
and say what's happening what's
happening you expect that thing to grow
because you know there's a law and a
process
and the seed will grow if it is in the
right soil and it has the right amount
of moisture
making it really a habit
and doing it every day
doing something every morning when you
wake up that's a really good time and
another good time is when you go to
sleep at night and and gratitude works a
lot you can't feel the emotion of your
future
your manifestation of love before it's
made manifest like people say well well
when my relationship hat when i find mr
right then i'm gonna feel love waiting
for the outer environment to change
[Music]
to take away this feeling of anger
resentment emptiness
but they forgot that they create reality
in other words when it finally appears
that i'm going to feel loved that's
that's cause and effect we're waiting
for something to happen if you're
feeling the lack and the emptiness
then you're keeping your relationship at
arm's length because you don't have the
magnetic field to draw to you
so
the emotions that come from these energy
centers the lower energy centers in our
body do have frequencies there's
chemistry involved
but they have a different agenda
so now we ask the person
can you teach
your body emotionally
what the future will feel like before
it's made manifest that means you can't
wait for your relationship to feel love
you have to reverse that battleship and
understand feeling love now is going to
be the magnet and if you can hold the
vision of your future a clear intention
with a coherent brain
organize signals into the field
and you could actually crack this thing
open
and
practice
getting so present in the moment
that you're not anticipating the next
moment or trying to predict the future
and you're no longer romancing the
emotions of your past you can find that
sweet spot of the generous present
moment
the familiar past is the known
emotionally the predictable future is
the habituation of autopilot being
unconscious in programs those are both
knowns there's only one place where the
unknown exists that's the present moment
so if you could work with your body
to the point that it trusts you enough
to feel so safe
that you have conquered it in a certain
way that it could actually relax into
the present moment and it's not worried
about what's going to happen next or
what's going on around around you or
that you need to eat you need to pee you
need to move you you got beyond all your
drives and you're you're ready to create
that moment where you're present
if you could begin to work with your
heart
and start to breathe and start to
practice feeling love in the beginning
it would feel foolish or gratitude why
would i feel love if it hasn't happened
well that's because you've been
hypnotized into waiting for your world
to change to feel feel the emotion from
the experience
but according to the quantum model
your emotion ahead of the experience
when you combine that clear intention
with the elevated emotion
and you feel love your body's so
objective
that it's actually believing it's living
in that future
in the present moment and your body now
is beginning to change
you are beginning to change your biology
to reflect
what you're about to experience in your
future
so the stronger the
love you feel the more altered you feel
inside of you the more you're going to
pay attention to that picture in your
mind stimulus response memory emotion
thought and feeling but now you're
remembering your future you're truly in
the present moment and you know exactly
what you want
and you
begin to teach your body emotion start
practicing opening that heart it's
amazing what happens
the moment that heart begins to open
we've measured this so many times lewis
on a scan on a real-time brain scan
when the heart moves into this kind of
rhythm when you're feeling
frustration
when you're feeling impatient when
you're feeling resentment you are
stepping on the gas pedal and you're
stepping on the brake at the same time
and the heart is pumping against the
closed system and it causes an erratic
beat it becomes incoherent and energy
literally leaves the heart now you no
longer believe in your future you can't
put your heart into your future you
can't trust the outcome because there's
no energy there it's it's being used and
consumed somewhere else so energy is
leaving the brain as well
but once energy starts to move into the
heart we've seen this so many times and
it starts to beat in this rhythm like
banging a drum or dropping a pebble in
water pebble after pebble the heart
begins to create a wave of energy right
to the brain like like taking a big
sheet
and going like that and then all of a
sudden you see this wave and the brain
gets this rush of energy and that change
in brain wave patterns that change that
wave is carrying information
and the person starts to get a very
clear idea they see their future very
clearly now now that energy is causing
them to move into very coherent alpha
brainwave patterns which is the state of
creation this is when you no longer hear
the voice in your head that's talking to
you that you listen to and believe is
the truth i'm not good enough yeah
whatever that is
that's called the default mode it
suppresses the default mode network and
the next thing you know
you start seeing in pictures and images
you start dreaming
and that's the imagination that's the
creative state so now you start
naturally imagining the heart is the
creative center we got to put our heart
into our future it better be open and
activated
so now when you start falling in love
with your future
oxytocin is released in the brain and in
the heart oxytocin signals nitric oxide
nitric oxide signals another chemical
called endothelial derived relaxing
factor and just like when your sexual
organs get filled with blood because
you're aroused the same thing happens
here as it would happen somewhere else
and literally the arteries in the heart
and lungs
engorge and now your heart feels full
and it's thumping in order and you're
in the present moment now once that
happens and it's beating in rhythm the
heart produces an external magnetic
field up to three meters wide now
you're in survival you're drawing from
the field and turning into chemistry
when you get energy in the heart it's
causing a change in the brain
and all of a sudden it's resetting the
baseline for trauma
and now here you have a magnetic field
now the heart
is your magnet it is it is the center of
creation and now that that energy is
frequency
and frequency carries information and
you can lay the thought of your new
relationship everything is possible you
know when you believe
that's
the kind of kicker you have to believe
but it's not that hard it's really
pretty easy
our belief creates our entire life
experience
and so you can't
if i put it this way you can't
experience anything in life
that is outside of your own beliefs if
we can't experience anything that's
outside of our beliefs
what that means is look at all those
hearts that's so beautiful
what that means is there's not really
one world we kind of think there's one
world but there isn't really because
we're all experiencing a world based on
our beliefs and not one of us has the
same beliefs not one of us so that means
there's a different world for every one
of us
so
all of your beliefs
are held in your subconscious mind and
the subconscious mind is just a part of
your mind there's the conscious mind and
then there's the subconscious mind
which is actually higher than the
conscious mind and so we use our
conscious mind with all of the thoughts
and everything that we have our
conscious mind is very present right
and so
to create anything
you are using your subconscious mind
your subconscious mind is what
is really what creates if i want to make
it really really simple then i would say
your subconscious mind is what creates
it makes things appear
and manifest things
and that's where all of your beliefs are
stored kind of neat huh
because you have to believe to manifest
something
and your subconscious mind creates
everything
so you can see it's all kind of
perfectly designed
um so now to manifest you have to
believe
and
you have to believe that you already
have whatever it is that you want and
the reason that you have to believe you
have it already is because the
subconscious mind
is only operating in the present
it can't reason it's just like a program
so if you say
for example
um
a new car is coming my new car is coming
i'm going to get a new car it's coming
well then it's always going to be coming
right that's the that's the thing you
have to imagine you have it now
you have to go off and you have to test
drive the car you've got to feel the car
smell the car
and just then
visualize being in that car
and then when you do that that's how
if you do that enough that's how you'll
come to believe that you actually have
the car and the moment that you believe
is manifestations instantaneous
so
so
the other ways to believe is to affirm
over and over and over um
so
to be really repetitive for example
um to visualize and visualizing is
incredibly powerful
because when we close our eyes and we
put ourselves in the picture and you
must make sure you're in the picture
and you put yourself in the picture with
whatever it is that you want and you
close your eyes and you just kind of
create this mini movie
honestly
the subconscious mind does not know that
you're imagining it has no idea
it just sees that movie and recreates it
it's like a giant photo copying machine
it will just whatever you hold in your
mind it will
photocopy it warm into the world
so
um so if you are thinking about
something in the future it's always
going to be in the future so you have to
imagine that you have it now you have to
act as if
and um for example
if you wanted to attract a perfect
partner
are you acting as if your perfect
partner is here already and so there are
just small things that you can do that
are super super powerful for example are
you sleeping in the middle of your bed
or are you sleeping on one side of the
bed because your partner's on the other
side of the bed
do you have room in your wardrobe for
your perfect partner's clothes
is there room in your bathroom for their
toothbrush and for their things and so
you see they are just little things you
can set the table for two you don't have
to put food on the plate but just
setting the table for two is really
really powerful it's saying my perfect
partners here already and the
subconscious mind will believe it
and your perfect partner will be
attracted to you through the most
incredible circumstances so
if something hasn't manifested yet and
you really really want it
and i i doubt there's anybody out there
who's
who wants something and it hasn't
manifested right i mean
um i'll tell you the reason why it
hasn't manifested is because you don't
believe you have it consciousness is
awareness awareness is paying attention
and noticing and so 95
of who we are by the time we're 35 years
old is a set of unconscious automatic
programs that we've just practiced so
many times that we're not consciously
thinking about those so in order for you
to change to answer the initial question
that you asked
the first step is you got to become
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
and you got to you got to start looking
at those hardwired thoughts that that
you think every day that are just
circuits that have been fired and wired
together how do we do that should we
write a list at the end of the day or
one of the most common thoughts we had
that day like how does someone become
aware you don't have to do that you just
have to sit down close your eyes and not
move and then you'll get you'll you'll
start seeing what am i thinking about
right now yeah and all you want to do is
observe the thought because
when you begin to observe that thought
you're no longer the program now you're
the consciousness observing the program
and you're starting to pull out of the
program but thinking about the thinking
yeah who's doing the thinking of the
thinking
about the thinking that's who you are
when you're not the program that's
awareness right you got to become aware
of how you speak how you act become so
conscious
so aware of it that you won't go
unconscious and let that thought or that
behavior run you you got to say oh my
god
this feeling that i've been living by
for the last 20 years is actually guilt
i didn't know it was guilt because it
just feels like me
and all of a sudden as you start
becoming conscious of it you're
beginning to objectify your subjective
self you're you're pulling out of those
programs and nobody likes to do that
because it's uncomfortable they'd rather
turn on their cell phone start texting
get on the internet you know you know
watch tv to distract them from that
moment and that is what they have to
move through in order to get to their to
their own personal freedom so the first
step is becoming conscious and
meditation means to become familiar with
to become conscious of to to become so
conscious
of your unconscious self that you won't
go unconscious to any thought any
behavior or emotion and get ready
because it takes a tremendous amount of
energy
to do that and awareness
to stay conscious and so
we fall from grace yeah fine you gotta
you got you're awake you got another day
let's go again how often do you fall oh
my gosh i mean
how many times have i done it thousands
but i'm not gonna give up because
the moments
in which i do connect or the moments
that i do have that transcendental
experience
what matters the most after it when i
have that transcendental moment i look
back
at all of those difficult meditations
those difficult days and those are the
ones you remember you don't remember the
good meditations you remember the ones
where you came up against yourself and
you went a little further and you said
i'm gonna go a little further and go a
little further
or
you had a rough day and you just went in
and you just you at the end of the day
you surrender and you have the classic
oh my god moment
there's no linear correlation it's just
whether you're willing to live in
creation instead of living in survival
and so
you get better at it you know we just
get better at it and for me um staying
conscious and staying aware and staying
present
is an art because
you you know when someone's present with
you in your life because they're paying
attention to you
you know when they're not present with
you because they're not paying attention
to you so
imagine this field of information this
this this intelligence that lives within
you and i that's governing everything
material in this world it's a
self-organizing intelligence
you have access to it so you better get
present with it
as well as you can get present with
anything else and just because you can't
see it
doesn't mean it doesn't exist
that that that realm you can't
experience with your senses you can only
experience with your awareness
so then
people have to take their attention off
their bodies and go from a somebody to a
nobody
take their attention off the people in
their life and go from that they
identify with and go from a someone to a
no one take their attention off the
things in their life their cell phone
their computer their car and go from
something to nothing take their
attention off where they sleep where
they work where they're sitting and go
from somewhere to nowhere take their
attention off the predictable future in
the familiar past and time and go from
some time to no time and now if you're
taking all of your attention off of
everything material in this
three-dimensional reality now there's
only one other thing that's left that
means you're an awareness your
consciousness and now
that is the bridge that is the door to
the quantum field and you can't enter
the quantum field as a somebody so
if someone has spent their whole life
working on having the perfect body or so
much so they have so much attention on
their pain
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy it's going to take
some work for them
to take all of their attention off their
body right because they'll go they'll do
it and then they'll go back let's see if
the pain's still there oh the pain is
still there so
it's a little bit of a waltz in the
beginning but as people start applying
this
you start getting better at it it's so
important then that of the infinite
places you can put your attention
let's put it on your heart
now where you place your attention is
where you place your energy why because
we want this center to bloom
hundred thirteen hundred different
chemicals that we storm regenerate the
body let's breathe let's open this up
let's practice this let's start learning
how to lead with our heart a different
consciousness yeah in the beginning
it's a little difficult but
you stay with it and you practice it
pedal by pedal by pedal placing your
attention there you're putting your own
life force
back into your heart you're turning your
love inward and the body will start
responding and in a week's time if we're
doing that three times a day or over and
over again
sooner or later that thing's going to
start blooming and just like when your
sexual organs are aroused and they're
engorged with blood
this center
when you start feeling love you make a
chemical called oxytocin
oxytocin signals nitric oxide
nitric oxide
signals a chemical called derived
endothelial relaxing factor you know
what that is
it causes the arteries in your heart to
literally open up so your heart is going
to be filled with blood and oxygen and
nutrients it's physiological it's going
to feel full
you're going to have a heart on in a
sense your heart is going to fill right
and when that happens
you experience a level of love
that passes all understanding you your
cup runneth over i mean it is
and people are in they're sobbing
because
they realize that this this center
finally like a child a community of
like-minded like like
similar energy of people
uh everybody understands they get one
another you know you you communities
tends to be the thing now that in terms
of our
uh social media and the feedback we're
getting
everybody wants more community because
you get a you get a thousand people an
audience and their energy synchronized
now you're looking at something so much
bigger we're just going to measure this
i just talked to a researcher yesterday
we're going to measure
a thousand people when they reach that
synchronized moment when they're we can
we know that the entire
social coherence in the room is orderly
then if you're producing a ambient
coherent magnetic field in your heart
and
you're tuning into a thought or an
intent and you got a thousand people
doing that and your energy is going to
start interfering and co-mingling with
the person that's next to you when that
energy starts to synchronize
it's going to produce a bigger wave the
higher the amplitude the higher the wave
the more energy there is so now you have
one mind and one heart and now when it
comes to healing others and we've done
the research on this now and we're
collecting the data that we're teaching
people how to administer
a change in energy in the person that's
laying there because it's not matter
that emits a field that's the wrong way
to think about it it's the field that
creates matter
you change the field you change matter
you're not it's not your job to change
the tumor the tumor is the illusion it's
the pattern in the field
that's that that has to be changed so
once people start reversing this then
you start seeing the tumors disappearing
you start seeing blind people seeing
deaf people hearing you start seeing
people with parkinson's disease switch
on i mean you start seeing
stage four cancers reversing because now
they're you're you're you're swimming
upstream you're going to the headwaters
and making that change i think we're all
faced with great opportunities
brilliantly disguised as impossible
situations
and in order like
for me personally and i and after
looking through your book and reading a
good portion of it
i mean for me there's there's no school
of ancient wisdom that you need to go to
to be initiated your life is your
initiation if you're paying attention so
we meet challenges in our life from a
certain level of mind right a certain
level of consciousness or
unconsciousness and even einstein said
we have to go to a greater level of
consciousness
than the consciousness that's created
the problem well what is consciousness
consciousness is awareness and awareness
means possibilities that you haven't
thought of before
so
we could we confront problems or
challenges in our life and as a side
note i was having breakfast with a
researcher just last week who's studying
what happens when we perceive a
condition in our environment as a
problem how it weakens the organism
they're measuring this and when a person
sees it as a challenge how they draw
energy they raise the energy of their
body back into order
so
if we said i want to be
wealthy or i want to be healthy
well what what you want to be that
because you're not it
so the initiation of going from not it
here to it here you're going to have to
climb some steps and there's going to be
some blind spots so you try it out and
it doesn't work
well that's because there's a part of
you that's still in a habit there's part
of you that's still unconscious okay so
what is it about myself and that
circumstance
that i am feeling
about that circumstance and that feeling
is causing me to think about it so you
say oh it's impossible they'll never
change i'll hire a hitman i'll hire the
mafia i'll hire an attorney i'll have my
friend's friend to talk to him and
nothing changes right well
you're not you're not separate
from that experience you're involved in
it and how you think and how you feel
broadcast energy into the field so your
energy is the same every day and as long
as your energy is the same nothing's
going to change in your life either and
nobody changes until they change their
energy so then
what piece of knowledge
what piece of information what would
love do what would greatness look like
okay i don't know
all right well certainly somebody in
history has faced this problem
don't get on facebook and say does
anybody have any answers don't get
go look it up and study and read and
learn you'll own it and you'll say wow
that person that was wealthy
they failed 500 times
well hell i had the wrong view of wealth
okay then failure is not a thing i got
to overcome failure well yep just
climbed a step yeah okay i'm reacting to
that circumstance with the same emotion
that emotion is firing the same thoughts
i'm broadcasting the same energy into
the field
if i were facing that circumstance and
situation again with that person that
circumstance what do i learn from that
circumstance how could i do it
differently the next time
find out a solution and rehearse it
install the circuitry so when you get in
the circumstance you're not going to
respond in an automatic habituation yeah
now you're at a greater level of
consciousness now you're looking at
possibilities that you weren't looking
at before because you were unconscious
now
that process of trial and error is so
important in the spiritual path
how many times
do we have to forget before we remember
and then we remember and we forget again
and it takes constantly remembering
until we stop forgetting and when we get
to that point now we're conscious now
there's wisdom and wisdom is the memory
of the experience without the emotional
charge now you're ready for the new
adventure so then
people draw conclusions and say oh it's
that person that ripped me off as that
person that
what now now you don't create your
reality you only create reality when
things are good
well somehow you got to tango through
this somehow your objectivity in not
reacting emotionally
is going to change the energy of how you
address this situation
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome to dive deeper into the
law of attraction check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there so when you think a deliberate
thought of what you want
then law of attraction will employ the
universe
and all people circumstances and events